the royal family back in business with
the prince and princess of Wales in
Wales new titles but familiar territory
Anglesey the couple's home for three
years they'd left before four-year-old
Theo was even born but that didn't stop
him waiting hours
a stop at the Lifeboat station and then
to Swansea
[Music]
Saint Thomas a church turned Community
hub from food bank to Baby bank and for
the crowds outside Smiles handshakes and
selfies we only phoned us this morning
that they were coming so it was exciting
times very nice to see them in Swansea
it's nice to think that they think
enough of us to come and visit and not
only that they've circulated everywhere
but of course not here the 35
000 who've signed a petition demanding
an end to the Prince of Wales title and
we now know there won't be another grand
investiture if it happens it'll be years
away
the king is thought to favor a slim down
monarchy that means beefed up rolls for
William and Kate now Prince and Princess
of Wales and it's no coincidence on the
day Royal morning ends they're starting
the new job here with very visible Welsh
walkabouts as flags at Royal residences
are raised to full mast these are
important but significant early days a
prince and princess of Wales launched
and the new king with a new Cipher its
roll out gradual but already on letters
leaving Buckingham Palace as Charles III
starts making his Mark as Monarch Laura
van duck Sky News Swansea